okay so I'm gonna do a card trick based
on the number 27 and this is my all-time
favorite math card trick I'm going to
show it for you today and I'm going to
explain it and I found this trick in an
old 1950s math book written by Martin
Gardner and for me it is the mass card
trick with the most beautiful maths
behind it out of all them and because it
is a math card trick it does involve a
lot of long tedious counting but bear
with us here so did this involve 27
cards so I'm going to take 27 off and
this is a genuine count 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 27 is actually one of my favorite
numbers 110 because it's a cube number 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 I guess 27 cards and this
works with any 27 cards and and none of
this trick is sleight of hand none of it
is a YouTube magic where I'm using
something sneaky or a sneaky edit and
I'll explain the trick afterwards so
it's ok but this is how it works you get
27 cards you shuffle them up I'm
actually going to get brady to both film
and be the volunteer so I'll flick
through which do you want to tap which
one you want which one of these just
just like that one there you want to
show the camera that color let me see it
obviously and you wanna put it back in
wherever you want I can always and do is
just remember what that card was and
believe me people in the comments will
mention upwards if you don't Oh Brady
what's your favorite number from 1 to 27
if you had to pick bigger number 10 10
any particular reason why 10 I just like
how it looks you're like ok are you
looking for your card by the way what I
want you to do is I have a look and see
if you can spot which pile your card
goes into and people may have seen this
trick done before it's a variation in
fact it's a generalization on a 21 card
trick which pile is it in it's in middle
part there okay I'm going to pick them
up from from well from the viewers right
to left and what people tend to do is
they do this tedious counting out each
time what I'm actually doing is last
time I memorized all the cards and so I
knew when you taught me which pile I've
narrowed it down to nine possible cards
it could be if I do it again because of
the way I'm dealing it out if you tell
me which pilots in this time I will
narrow it down to one
of three possible cards which pile is it
in the stock this time it is in it's in
the middle one again there we are
getting pure coincidence I'll pick them
up again and then we'll do it one last
time again dividing by three and this is
why 27 is 3 cubed if you say which one
it's in I will know having memorized all
the cards exactly 1 in 1 I will know
precisely which card it is and that's
just the pure information of this trick
which ones do all over that cook ok so
now to be fair all of that wasn't true
were the numbers were true and the
number of cards it could have been going
from 27 to 9 to 3 to 1 that's completely
accurate I wasn't bothering to memorize
and I was doing something else slightly
different um what was your card you can
tell me now it was the king of her King
of Hearts present what was your favorite
number 10 okay watch this here we go
ready 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 King of
Hearts so this trick you can put the
card if you know you don't know what it
is as long as they tell you which pilots
in you can put it anywhere in that deck
so if you say any number after 3 lots of
dealing it out I can put the card into
that position and that is my all-time
favorite maths paste card trick do you
wonder how it works yes this is this is
brilliant
ok so can I have some of your famous
brown paper alright ok excellent now
let's look at why this trick works now
ok you're going to bear with me here I'm
going to set up a slightly unusual way
to look at the cards because when you
get the 27 cards the very last step if
we go from the end of the trick I pick
them up into there were three piles of
nine cards let's say from now I'm going
to call the top one the zeroth pile and
then the first pile on the second pile
and there's a reason for that in a
moment but just bear with me while I set
up some notation so when the cards go
back together there are nine cards in
the top pile 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so that
was why I called the 0th pile on top
then there was 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 in the
first pile and the bottom one 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9
that was the second part and as it turns
out your one was the King of Hearts that
ended up being the tenth card down that
was because you said the very beginning
you said if ever number is ten and
you're King of Hearts ended up there and
so now when you think about it these top
three from the final pass because this
is the very last top middle and bottom
pile that top one came from the previous
top piles that was the previous 0th pile
that was the previous middle pile that
was the previous bottom tile that was
the previous top middle bottom top
middle bottom and so actually if you
watch it you can see how that happens
because I've picked them up from the
second time I've got the top the middle
in the bottom packets each of nine cards
I put them together
I deal out the next three piles and the
first three come from that top pack of
nine and then the next three come from
that top pack of nine and then the next
three from the same top pack a nine so
that's why over here
the top three come from the previous top
0th pile the next three of each one come
from the middle pile so that's the net
first three off the middle next three
off the middle next three off the middle
and I've got nine left that was the
previous bottom pile and that's why now
I get three from the bottom three for
the bottom three from the bottom so they
end up going down like that and then
actually within those and if you get
some cards and you start playing around
with this within the final ordering it
turns out from the very very first time
you put them together this is the top
the middle the bottom the top the middle
the bottom the top the middle the bottom
the top then don't don't lose too much
sleep over exactly why this happens if
you get a pack of cards and deal it
you'll start to see why and what you end
up here is this is the ordering from the
first time we dealt the cards out that's
the ordering from the second time we
dealt the cards out and that's the
ordering from the third time we got the
cards out and to get it here at tenth I
can see that to get this position here
it's the zero zero first or top top
middle and so when each time Brady point
to where his card was the first time I
put that pile back on top the second
time I put that pile and back on top
the third tire put that pile in the
middle sashka to secondary in fact very
do you wanna pick a different number so
say I told you my favorite number was 13
what would you have done
okay so 13 I need to put 12 cards on top
of that and 12 is 1 9 1 3 and no units
so I'm going to put that on the top the
middle the middle 13 is 9 10 11 12 13
Yesi 0 top middle middle that the way I
work it out is I'm actually working a
tower in base 3 because this whole trick
uses base 3 ternary numbers which I
think are absolutely amazing and the
first time you put the piles back
together you're doing the unit's column
of your base 3 number the next time you
put them back together you're doing
threes column and then the last time
you're doing the ninth column and so
when you give me your number
I work out that number in base 3 and
then that tells me how to put the piles
back together ok so now we're going to
redo the very first trick I did in
effective almost slow motion in
annotated mode if you will and so you
had a look at one card and then I
started dealing these and then I talked
to you about your favorite number you
said 10 you're looking for the King of
Hearts and I'm thinking how am I gonna
get that King of Hearts or I don't know
what card is how am I going to get
whatever the card is to the 10th
position and 10 9 goes into that once
and so I want to get 9 cards on top so I
actually have to put it in the top the
top and in the middle so has the King of
Hearts come past yeah where was it it
was there ok so now I now know it has to
go top top middle so when I pick them up
from left to right these two I don't
care about that can be bottom that can
be middle the King of Hearts is in this
one so it has to go on top which means
it's going to be one of the first nine
to get dealt out and so it's going to be
either the top card or the next piles or
the second card in the next part which
happens to
be over the third card and then the rest
we actually don't care about because
there's other two piles I know it wasn't
in those these are just padding to get
it into the correct position so now
which one was it
middle one okay so again it's top top
middle says to go top again if you watch
when I picked them up I still pick them
up in the same order but I put them
together in a different order so that
goes on top and then I get this last one
and I'll just shove it underneath so now
I know it's on top in fact I know it's
in the top three of the top pile so when
I go down this time it has to be the top
cart there it is
and then the rest go on top and then the
last time it has to go in the middle and
so you can kind of see what's going to
happen now because if it goes in the
middle it's going to get nine cards put
on top of it it's going to be the top
card in the middle pile it's going to be
the tenth card so it was in this one
well how about that pick that one up
first pick that one up and put it
underneath so it's the middle one put
that one underneath like that and so now
it has to be the tenth card one two
three four five six seven eight nine so
in fact one way you can think about it
is I drawing a time versus card height
diagram and so the first time you do it
this is the first time you deal out
you've got the bottom pack you've got
the middle pack and you've got the top
pack when you put them back together and
the reason I use 0 1 & 2 is that your
units column in ternary the second time
you've got the bottom pack you've got
the middle pack you've got the top pack
and again at 0 1 & 2 and that's the
second time you deal and then the third
time you deal again you've got the
bottom the middle pack and the top
bandits are at one enters they're the 3
packs when you put them back together
and in fact this is your units column or
that that's your ones column that
there's your threes column and that
there's your 9s column so any numbers if
you want to put let's say 15 on top to
get 15 you're going to need two threes 1
9 and no units so it's going to go top
bottom middle to put 15 cards on top and
end up being the 16th card if someone at
home wants
do this trick do they have to be pretty
good at maths there you have two options
you can either be pretty good at maths
or you can spend a lot of your free time
practicing until your brain gets used to
doing this which to be fair both exactly
the same thing
maths is all about practicing something
and developing a new way of thinking for
your brain to get used to it so I mean
either option learn maths or learn card
tricks you're ending up with the same
skill set to be asked you said at the
start this was your favorite trick to
some extent it is what what is that that
there are lots of tricks what is it
about that one that resonates with you
well I like the on one hand it takes a
trick a lot superman' people know the 21
card trick where you put it back in the
middle each time and then it ends up
being the middle card and so people kind
of know that they don't know why it
works whereas this one you know why it
works and then you can do it so much
more with it and there's a huge
difference in math did anything between
just memorizing the steps so you know
how to do it versus knowing why those
steps get you where you want to be and
so this utilizes the advantage of
knowing why the steps are doing
something and then you can tweak it as
you go so instead of always putting it
in the middle you can put it anywhere
you want because you understand how it
works
because you're putting three piles back
together three times there are 27
possible arrangements of putting it back
across the trick which correspond to all
27 possible positions in fact you can do
this trick with a lot more cards if you
really want to you can do it with as
many it's the number of piles to the
power of how many times you deal the
cards out if you get 10 billion cards
which is a lot of cards and you deal
them out into 10 piles ten times you can
put any of those ten billion cards into
any position just through ten deals
although middlee you aren't you are
dealing and million cards into each
parser to take a very long time in fact
in Martin Gardner's book magic maths and
mystery he describes it if you want to
do the 10 million card version his sorry
10 billion card version his
recommendation is to be very very
careful as you're doing the 10 piles of
10 each time because if you make a
mistake
very few audiences will sit through that
trick for a second time